does your parents worry about you
really really uh my mom was worried when
I went to London
um
no I mean
with all the
because I mean nobody can really prepare
you for what it is that you're facing
right now as far as like all of the
pushback and love hate you know
interacting with different people
content creators they do reactions to
you and your stuff or whatever someone
is like they don't worry about you from
that lens and that oh my God you know I
don't want them to say nothing about my
Pearl
see my parents don't worry they just
help so if there's a problem like
they're not going to sit there worrying
about it they're just going to figure
out how to solve it so like if I come to
my dad and I'm like I'm worried about
this this and this he's just gonna give
me like three different ways to solve it